[Musica]
ma davvero pensate che siano soltanto i
vostri figli o le vostre figlie che si
debbano allenare quando le accompagnate
alla scuola calcio o alla società
sportiva
pensate invece che dovreste allenarvi
anche voi tutte le teorie gli studi le
ricerche la letteratura sul talento ci
dicono che questo talento è composto da
qualcosa che è genetico ma che per
esprimersi al meglio del suo potenziale
questo talento ha bisogno di essere
inserito in un contesto adesso
favorevole che cos'è il contesto ben
estrema sintesi il contesto potremmo
definirlo come le relazioni che ciascun
talento riesce a sviluppare con i propri
pari l'insieme delle relazioni che il
talento riesce a sviluppare quelle
figure adulte che in qualche modo sono
coinvolte nel suo processo formativo e
l'insieme anche delle relazioni che
tutte le figure adulte riescono a
sviluppare tra di loro e tra queste
figure adulte oltre agli allenatori ai
componenti dei vari staffa le figure
dirigenziali ci siete anche voi genitori
ci siamo anche noi genitori
e allora per poter adempiere un compito
così importante non possiamo pensare che
il nostro allenamento rispetto alla
conoscenza del gioco del calcio inteso
come strumento formativo si riduca
quello che ascoltiamo nelle trasmissioni
televisive
tanto più che oggi sempre di più il
calcio è vissuto e raccontato come se
fosse uno sport individuale
individualista dove si esalta chi fa gol
chi risolve le partite
per carità è sempre stato così ma ci
stiamo davvero allontanando da quella
che è la bellezza corale del calcio
questa bellezza che porta in sé
una serie di valori che sono tecnici e
che poi diventano educativi e formativi
che sono una relazione la collaborazione
del rispetto reciproco la fiducia
reciproca e la solidarietà nei confronti
di coloro che sono meno bravi
il problema è che poi portiamo questo
modo di pensare nella nostra realtà
nelle nostre scuole calcio nelle nostre
società sportive e nostro figlio è bravo
lo saniamo solo se assoluto protagonista
solo che se è colui che fa gol
me ne sapete cosa dice
marcelo bielsa marcelo bielsa è il
tecnico che ha da poco portato in
premier league elezione ti credo che sia
tra i tecnici uno dei più gravi dal
punto di vista formativo e non solo ma
se lo bielsa dice questo un tecnico una
squadra è tanto più forte quanto più
riesce a comprendere l'importanza di
salvaguardare e di sostenere l'anello
più debole
adesso facciamo un gioco semplice per
alzata di mano vediamo chi si ricorda di
eric cantona va da qualcuno siete siete
abbastanza eric cantona re un giocatore
di calcio che negli anni 90 ha trascorso
diverse stagioni del manchester united
era uno che risolveva le partite con i
suoi gol
venne addirittura votato dai supporter
del manchester united come giocatore del
secolo bene al termine della sua
carriera calcistica intraprendere una
nuova carriera diventa attore in un film
il mio amico eric interpreta se stesso
il mio amico eric è la storia di un
signore di mezza età di professione fa
il postino che ha avuto un sacco di e
cantona una sera si personifica nella
casa di questo postino e diventa da quel
momento il suo confidente e un giorno
mentre stanno portando la posta in un
palazzo il postino si ferma e chiede
accantona eric qual è stato il momento
migliore della tua carriera
cantona ci pensa un attimo e dice non è
stato un gol ma come non è stato un gol
gli dice il postino deve essere stato
per forza un gol tu nei fatti così tanti
e comincia a raccontarli tutti i gol
perché lui sa tutti a memoria cantonale
lascia parlare un po e poi gli dice e
stato un passaggio del postino si blocca
un attimo e poi si illumina e dice ma
certo quel passaggio quello che tu hai
fatto air wing lui controlla la palla la
mette a terra e pum batte il portiere
degli spurs ma se lui avesse sbagliato
dice il postino accantona cantona
risponde di avere fiducia nei tuoi
compagni
ecco vedete come anche un giocatore come
cantona che risolveva le partite da solo
sottolinea la fiducia l'importanza della
fiducia in campo tra i compagni ma c'è
un altro giocatore forse ancora più
bravo
almeno per quello che ha fatto vedere in
campo che ci dice qualcosa in questa
direzione vediamo se indovinate giocava
con la maglia numero 10 della sua
nazionale con le strisce verticali
celesti e bianchi chi maradona si
proprio lui maradona
nel 1986 nel campionato del mondo del
messico nel quarto di finale con la sua
argentina a fronte all'inghilterra
l'argentina vincerà 2 a 1 e maradona
signora due gol il primo con quella che
lui chiamerà la mano di dios la mano di
dio allora non c'era il var e quindi è
stato convalidato e il secondo gol lo
segna facendo un'azione fantastica
prende palla a metà campo dribla quasi
tutti gli avversari e sull'uscita del
portiere con un rasoterra mette la palla
in rete
ebbene sapete cosa dice maradona
nelle interviste successive a quella
partita dice certo che sono stato bravo
driblato quasi tutti gli avversari ma se
non avessi avuto a fianco a me valdano
che correva in qualche modo distraeva i
miei avversari che non sapevano se io
avrei dato a lui la palla o sarei andato
verso di loro punto per trib l'harley di
volta in volta forse quel gol non sarei
mai riuscito a farlo
ecco vedete con un campione come
maradona anche qui in un'azione che ai
più è soltanto individuale sottolinea
come ci sia relazione che non ci sia
collaborazione all'interno del gioco del
calcio maradona aveva il mondo nelle sue
mani e stato un talento straordinario ma
sono tante storie di talenti
straordinari che non sono riusciti poi a
dimostrare il talento che avevano nel
tempo questa è la storia quella che li
andrò a raccontare del piccolo goldrick
il piccolo oltre che era un giocatore
con un talento incredibile anche lui
prendeva palla tripla va tutti gli
avversari risolveva le partite e gli
adulti lo sapevano
lo sapevano gli spettatori lo sapevano
l'allenatore e tutti i componenti degli
staff e dirigenti lo sapevano i genitori
quindi ogni volta che si aspettava che
lui e risolvere le partite
e quando le partite diventano difficili
l'allenatore si alzava e diceva goldrake
inventa e goldrake inventava londra e
prendeva palla per ibla va tutti e
risolveva le partite
poi però col tempo le cose cominciano a
complicarsi perché gli avversari
diventarono più forti
cominciarono ad organizzarsi e lo stesso
piccolo goldrick come tutti i bambini a
un certo punto è un momento di crescita
deve risistemare la tua coordinazione
quella generale ma anche quella
specifica che serve proprio a giocare al
calcio e allora le cose cominciano a
diventare difficili non riusciva più a
saltare l'avversario
cos'era successo era successo che nelle
difficoltà nessuno nessuno nessuno degli
adulti che ancora si aspettavano che lui
risolvesse le partite era stato in grado
di far riscoprire il valore del compagno
quanto il compagno avesse potesse in
qualche modo risolvere insieme a lui un
problema di gioco una situazione di
gioco così con il tempo è subentrata la
frustrazione nel piccolo goldrick è un
giorno è andato nella sede della sua
società nell'ufficio del direttore
sportivo in segno di resa buttato a
terra il borsone ha lasciato per sempre
il calcio
accanto una storia così triste ci sono
poi quelle storie che possiamo definire
delle piccole imprese sportive ed è
quella degli allievi under 16 della
cimina nella stagione 2016 2017
quella era una squadra che giocava
davvero un calcio corale bellissimo
eppure ad un certo punto della stagione
poco prima della pausa per le vacanze
pasquali
la squadra non era nelle prime cinque
della classifica e quindi non avrebbe
partecipato ai play off finali
i primi a essere preoccupati sono erano
sicuramente i ragazzi perché sapete no
tutti quanti i bambini ragazzi sono i
primi a voler vincere però a questo
punto la differenza l'hanno fatta le
figure adulte l'ha fatta certamente
l'allenatore gli staff i dirigenti ma
credetemi l'hanno fatta probabilmente
soprattutto i genitori i genitori con la
loro consapevolezza e spronare i propri
figli a continuare a giocare un certo
tipo di calcio
questa bellezza con re del calcio questo
calcio che porta a porta valore avrebbe
determinato il valore del loro percorso
nel loro percorso formativo
e questo valore avrebbe poi determinato
il valore dell'esito finale
indipendentemente dal valore numerico
indipendentemente da una vittoria e
della sconfitta
allora la squadra così sostenuta ha
partecipato ad un torneo medio livello
vince il torneo ritorno in campionato e
inanella una serie di vittorie che le
permettono di arrivare alle prime cinque
accede alla fase finale
e qui incontra prima la juventus vince 5
0 poi va a interello e vince nuovamente
5 a 0 dopo che aveva perso nella
stagione regolare per ben due volte
arriva la sfida la doppia sfida con
l'atalanta probabilmente una delle
squadre favorite per la vittoria finale
vince in casa 3 a 1 e perde 2 a 1
bergamo ma questo non impedisce di
accedere appunto alla finalissima che si
giocherà in romagna finalissima che
prevede una semifinale che giocano
contro il genova e con un pizzico di
fortuna riescono a vincere 1 0 e la
finalissima con la roma vinta per 5 2
la squadra si laurea campione d'italia
e certamente la vittoria dei giocatori
nei ragazzi sono loro che vanno in campo
ma è stata la vittoria delle figure
adulte e stata la vittoria del contesto
di quel contesto che le figure adulte
hanno saputo creare
indipendentemente da quello che poi
sarebbe stato il risultato finale
la pensate ancora nello stesso modo
[Applauso]